hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar
laboratory screening for multiple
myeloma
a nudge in the direction of guidelines
compliance
i'm alexis krause of labberts and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labberts
and brought to you by bindingsite to
learn more
please visit bindingsite.com we
encourage you to participate today by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation you may
also submit any technical issues here as
well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
jeremy hart
medical director of clinical labs at st
elizabeth healthcare
dr hart welcome you may now begin
your presentation
good morning everyone i first want to
thank lab roots
for the privilege of joining you
virtually today
certainly um covet has created many
challenges for all of us
but on the other hand it's really opened
up greater opportunities
to connect virtually and i really
appreciate this opportunity to do just
that
if you're a laboratorian like me you
have line of sight into the ordering
behavior
of all the clinical providers in your
hospital
or your system and with that position of
privilege as someone who does have line
of sight numerous examples may come to
your mind
in which you observe patterns of test
ordering that aren't entirely
optimal it happens all the time in
healthcare
and i'm sure that our industry is not
unique in that regard
we've all experienced this you know over
utilized tests
contribute to waste in health care on
the other hand
underutilized utilized tests represent
missed opportunities
so the real question becomes what is
your strategy to nudge your system
in the direction of best diagnostic
laboratory practice
what's your go-to role are you a pusher
are you a puller as a laboratorian
how do you nudge your clinicians in the
optimal direction
without coming across as pushy which
honestly would be
counterproductive so i say we lay aside
any tendencies that we might have to
push
or to pull or drag our colleagues
along with us and really consider what
it might mean instead
to nudge them it's certainly true that
no matter how
effective a set of particular diagnostic
laboratory tests
clinicians still are in the position
where they have to select them
for their patients so a nudge
is a way for us to help them select the
right tests in a very respectful
collaborative way and so i think we
should keep in mind
that our decisions are heavily
influenced by the environment in which
they occur and this has really been
studied
very extensively by groups like u-pin
with their nudge units for ordering
providers in the context of laboratory
test decisions this environment includes
the electronic medical record
so small changes to the way test order
choices are presented
and how those orders are framed within
the emr
really can lead to significant
differences in the way clinicians order
tests
so what i hope to share with you today
is the story of how my system
has begun to leverage the emr to
optimize testing for multiple myeloma
and related diseases
so first let me tell you a little bit
about our system
at st elizabeth healthcare our mission
is to provide comprehensive
and compassionate care that improves the
health of the people we serve
and our vision is that saint elizabeth
would leave the communities we serve
to become the healthiest in america
every year our health system located in
the greater cincinnati region
provides more than 130 million dollars
in uncompensated care and benefit to our
community
we have six facilities throughout
northern kentucky
and southeastern indiana in addition to
that we have 165
specialty and primary care offices which
are located in the tri-state area
consisting of kentucky
ohio and indiana and we're home to 10
000 associates
and a medical staff of nearly 1200
physicians and advanced practice
providers
every year we have over 50 000
acute admissions or observations
and over 3 million patient encounters
i want to give you a sense of our our
laboratories as well
we operate a joint venture core
laboratory in partnership with
another large health system in the
greater cincinnati region
in addition to that core laboratory we
have nine hospital-based labs
with an annual operating budget of about
70 million dollars
our laboratories employ over 400
full-time equivalents
and we have 10 pathologists on staff
every year
we have approximately 6 million billable
tests
so in the context of myeloma testing
just to give you a sense
of the volume of testing that we have we
performed about 3 400 total
electrophoresis studies
in the last calendar year that was 2020.
so here are the key topics that we'll
cover in our session today
we'll begin by briefly covering the
classification and epidemiology of
plasma cell neoplasms
next we'll review testing approaches
and guidelines and after that i'm going
to share how my system
uncovered what type of testing was
actually occurring
how we leveraged our laboratory
information system to improve
and how we've monitored for efficacy
so first let's start with a brief review
of plasma cell neoplasms
those include the proliferative
disorders the most
important of which is multiple myeloma
there are also a handful of important
diseases that have low
low tumor burden and they exert their
primary effects
by the production of abnormal proteins
among those
are primary amyloidosis as well as light
chain deposition disease
and finally there are the pre-malignant
conditions and we'll spend a bit of time
looking at one of those conditions later
on and that's monoclonal gammopathy of
undetermined significance or
mgus each of these diseases has a wide
range of biology and disease
presentation and the first
clue to the diagnosis often is the
identification
of a monoclonal immunoglobulin
the malignant disease multiple myeloma
usually presents with a significant
amount of m-protein
but keep in mind there are also
non-secretory cases
with little to no m-protein on the other
hand the low tumor burden diseases like
amyloidosis
or life-change deposition disease may
only have
small amounts of them protein but their
clinical implications
may be severe requiring early diagnosis
and intervention
and even for the less common plasma cell
disorders they represent disease states
in which diagnostic guidelines exist
and where optimal test choices can
impact patient care in a positive way
so multiple myeloma of course is the
most important of the plasma cell
neoplasms
and it usually presents as tumorous
masses that are
scattered throughout the skeletal system
the clinical features of the disease
stem from the effects of a number of
important factors among those
are plasma cell growth in tissues and
the production of excess
immunoglobulin bone resorption often
leads to pathologic fractures and
chronic pain
these are things that often lead
patients to present clinically for care
in the radiographic images provided on
the slide
some characteristic lytic lesions are
depicted
in addition the pathologic fractures and
chronic pain
associated with skeletal involvement
there are other clinical features
uh that may present manifestations of
hypercalcemia for example
and and that can really involve multiple
organ systems
and can include non-specific symptoms
like constipation
fatigue or depression things that really
normally wouldn't be easily attributable
to a plasma cell disorder
renal disease is a very uh is also very
important to consider
among numerous factors contributing to
renal damage
uh is the toxicity of the excreted light
chains in renal tubular epithelial cells
and then finally there are the typical
hematologic manifestations
of plasma cell disorders and that
includes anemia
so compared to solid tumors
lung cancer breast cancer for example
multiple myeloma is relatively less
common
however according to statistics provided
by the american cancer society in
2021 nearly 35 000 individuals will be
diagnosed with multiple myeloma
and of those 35 000 new cases slightly
more than half of those are predicted to
be in men
[Music]
the incidence is also expected to be
higher
in individuals of african descent and
also keep in mind that it's chiefly a
disease of older adults
and the peak incidence is generally in
the age range of 65 to 70 years old
in fact really fewer than 2 percent of
all new cases
occur in individuals who are younger
than 35
again according to statistics from the
american cancer society
in 2021 approximately twelve thousand
deaths are expected to occur from
multiple myeloma
and the disease itself actually
represents about one percent of all
cancer deaths in western countries
uh with a lifetime risk of 1 in 132.
so several new treatment options have
been uh fda approved in recent years
targeted therapy
immunotherapy for example and what these
drugs are doing really is extending the
life of multiple myeloma patients
so if you look at our regional patient
population
again in the greater cincinnati ohio
region we've seen an
uptick in our identification of patients
diagnosed with
diagnosed with multiple myeloma
in each of the last two years in which
cancer registry data was available to me
again these were the years 2017 and 2018
we
identified nearly 40 new cases
in each of those years
so just as new treatments are extending
the life of multiple myeloma patients
early detection is also a very important
strategy
mgus i mentioned that earlier monoclonal
gammopathy of
undetermined significance is considered
a precursor state
and i think it's important in this
presentation to highlight our current
understanding of mgus progression
kyle and his colleagues at mayo have
written extensively on the topic of
mgus so they reported in
2006 on a cohort of over 1300 patients
who were diagnosed with mgus in
southeast minnesota
and they published that the probability
of progression
was determined to be around one percent
per year
with a cumulative probability of 30
percent
at 25 years
some predictors of the progression of
mgus
to myeloma included the size of m
protein so important
to point out that there's nearly a 50
risk of progression for those
who have an initial m protein of at
least 25 grams per liter
the type of involved heavy chain may
also predict progression
as there is an increased risk of
progression for
igm isotype other predictors include the
percentage of bone marrow plasma cells
and the serum free light chain ratio
importantly the serum free light chain
ratio may predict progression
independently of the size and type
of monoclonal protein
now let's shift our focus to different
test approaches
and i really like to share this
publication it's a great publication by
jonathan
ginsen from 2018 and that highlighted
the most common approaches
used by ordering physicians when
screening for monoclonal gammopathy
so just to point out some of the serum
tests that are used for screening and
diagnosis
those include serum protein
electrophoresis
there's a couple different methods for
serum protein electrophoresis that
includes agarose gel electropresis which
we do in my laboratory
also capillary zone electrophoresis
that's in addition to immunofixation
electrophoresis
serum for light chain studies and
quantitative immunoglobulins
uh urine studies may also be important
in some cases so urine
protein electrophoresis and urine
immunofixation
may be used to identify vince jones
protoneuria
so ginsen's work again published in 2018
was the
was the result of an international
survey of laboratory practice
um so this survey uh included labs
uh 700 different labs from 38 countries
so it was a wide sample
so they completed the survey and one of
the most interesting findings
uh in this study really was the response
to the question
what is the most common approach used by
physicians who send specimens
to your lab for initial evaluation
so the response has really demonstrated
significant variation in practice
uh the most common approaches these are
highlighted in the red
uh box on this slide were serum protein
electrophoresis with reflex to
immunofixation
serum protein electrophoresis alone or
the combination of serum protein
electrophoresis and immunofixation
and together those three different
approaches comprise
over 70 percent of total responses
importantly what all three of those
approaches have in common
is that they lacked the addition of
serum free life change studies
so the other thing that they pointed out
in the study was that fewer than half of
labs
offered panel testing for ordering
convenience
so the study really highlighted at least
one if not more
important gaps and really the gap i'm
thinking of here is the exclusion of
free light chain studies
but so important because serum free
light chains are very important
biomarkers for the diagnosis and the
management of plasma cell disorders
in multiple myeloma for example the
determination of free light chains
is used not only in the initial
diagnostic assessment
but also used during follow-up
just for example a normalized kappa
lambda ratio which is determined by
serum free light chains
is one of a handful of criteria used for
the determination of stringent complete
response
along with the negative ife in
saramander urine and plasma
cells in bone marrow less than five
percent
so the importance of serum free light
chain studies as a biomarker
was actually highlighted by the
introduction of a new definition of
multiple myeloma disease
and according to their the
recommendations of the international
myeloma working group or imwg
the ratio of involved to non-involve
free light chains
helps to differentiate between
smoldering multiple myeloma
and multiple myeloma that requires
treatment
in fact in the imwg's 2014 update
a free light chain ratio greater than
100 is is considered a myeloma defining
event
even more recently if you look in
publications even from last year
new criteria for high-risk smoldering
multiple myeloma were defined
there's a new rule called the two 2020
rule
and that consists of a serum protein
level of greater than 2 grams per liter
a free light chain ratio greater than 20
and bone marrow plasma cells greater
than 20 percent
and and patients who meet these criteria
tend to be a subgroup of smoldering
multiple
myeloma patients who have an increased
rate of progression within two years
and these patients may benefit from
early treatment intervention
so in plasma cell disorders other than
multiple myeloma
the assessment of free light change is
also very very crucial
and it has potentially wider
implications in treatment decisions
as i mentioned earlier amyloidosis and
light chain deposition these
disease may have only a small end
protein it may not be detectable
by sera protein electrophoresis so
assessment of free light chains is very
crucial
uh therapeutic response in both primary
amyloidosis and light chain deposition
disease
is nearly solely based on the percentage
and absolute decrease
of involved to non-involve free light
chains so honestly
we can't overstate the importance of
including serum free light chains in
both diagnostic
and monitoring strategies
this is another great study by katzman
published back 12 years ago and in this
study katzman demonstrated the
sensitivity
of different screening approaches for
different plasma cell disorders
this was on a cohort of over 1800
patients
so a number of studies including this
one have shown that the addition of
serum free light change studies to
protein electrophoresis can replace the
need for urine studies
and multiple myeloma now a key finding
in this uh study by katzman was that no
test
performed optimally when used as a
single screening test
when considering just the task
of screening for multiple myeloma really
just a simple screening panel of protein
electrophoresis and free light chains
was shown to be adequate and you can see
that
highlighted here in the upper
red box on the slide
the sensitivity of that combination of
test four the identification of multiple
myelomas was shown to be 100
however for other diseases and you can
see
in the bottom two rows primary
amyloidosis and light chain deposition
disease
urine studies really should not be
omitted in those
you know if you're looking for those
diseases in order to maximize
sensitivity
and you can see at the bottom there
moving
to a combination of all tests which
includes both serum and urine studies as
well as serum free light chains
results in the optimal sensitivity when
you're
looking for amyloidosis or light chain
deposition disease
so certainly using the most
comprehensive panel uh
serum and urine test was shown to be the
most sensitive that makes sense
but because of the small incremental
increase in sensitivity
really in most cases the use of sterile
protein electrophoresis and free light
chains
provides a very simple and cost
effective initial diagnostic screen
for the high tumor burden diseases like
myeloma
so for all these reasons mentioned in
the prior slides
it's the combined use of protein
electrophoresis and free light chains
which is recommended by the imwg
and the nccn also supports a use of a
panel of tests including serum free
light chains
in the initial diagnostic workup and
what i anticipate will happen later on
this year is that the college of
american pathologists is soon going to
publish a series of diagnostic
recommendations which will further
support
what is the optimal approach for
laboratories
so after understanding the guidelines
it really was important for me as a
laboratory director
to pivot to a key question
and that key question was how was saint
elizabeth healthcare doing
with regard to adhering to the published
evidence
and really this is the question that led
my team
and me down the path of discovery
so here at st elizabeth healthcare we
utilize
the epic emr as well as the epic beaker
laboratory information system
and these systems have several tools
that can assist with discovery
so we queried epic beaker using a
reporting workbench tool for all related
tests
ordered during the period beginning
november 2018 and ending november 2019.
we did make a few assumptions we we made
the assumption that
non-oncology clinicians were testing to
screen for multiple myeloma
while oncology initiating testing was
predominantly for the purpose of
confirmation or
for monitoring purposes so then we
calculated guideline compliance rates
by specialty and so what we discovered
after our audit
and these are actually results that we
published in a 2020 aacc annual meeting
abstract
was that there were 11 unique testing
combinations ordered
uh during about about four thousand
individual patient encounters
so around 55 percent of the encounters
were in non-oncology settings
and these encounters honestly were the
ones we were most interested in
understanding and if you look in the
middle column here that highlights
the approaches used by primary care
providers
they quite honestly demonstrated the
lowest adherence to current guidelines
at over 10 percent
just over 10 percent adherence so the
green boxes that are highlighted in this
column represent test combinations that
would be considered
compliant with guidelines
importantly we observed a significant
number
of serum protein electrophoresis only
orders
and those comprised 139
of the approaches in the primary care
setting
the total number of protein
electrophoresis orders
uh that lacked the recommended serum
free light chain studies comprised more
than 80
of encounters in the primary care
setting and so this was worrisome
to me as a laboratory director
and on a broader scale 63 percent
of all non-oncology orders were
comprised of test combinations
without recommended free light change
studies or in some cases urine studies
now if you compare my system to the
findings of ginzan
remember he found that 72 percent
of the respondents were not
adherent to guidelines in 2018 um
perhaps our system performed a little
bit better than
than that group but still there was
certainly
opportunity for improvement in our
system
so what i have found working with
clinicians
is that encouraging adherence to a
diagnostic test guideline
if that's an end into itself really
isn't perceived by clinicians as a
motivating force
but on the other hand what really should
be motivating to all of us in healthcare
is the opportunity to reduce the time to
diagnosis
so using a model originally published at
the 2017 american society for hematology
annual meeting
we theorized here in our system that
there would be a significant reduction
in the time to diagnosis
from 149 days with my current
system with my system's current pattern
of utilization
down to 45 days if following the
recommended guidelines
and really this difference could
positively impact
avoidance of downstream complications
and their associated costs things like
chronic renal impairment
infections and neurologic or bone
disease things that tend to
cost a lot of health care dollars
so um affecting change
looks differently at every institution
and the laboratory is going to be
positioned
differently in different institutions
different systems
at my institution significant changes
to the laboratory formulary or other
impactful changes are first vetted
through the clinical laboratory advisory
committee
or we like to call clack for short
this is a multi-disciplinary
physician-led committee that's been
around for about two years
and this group is responsible for
promoting and facilitating test
optimization opportunities in a fiscally
responsible manner
so when we launched this committee we
ensured
that it reported up the leadership chain
within the organization
to the medical executive committee and
had the backing of the medical executive
committee
so in addition to reviewing and
approving order sets containing
diagnostic tests
other examples of our past projects have
included
restriction of q24 hour laboratories
prevention of duplicate
once-in-a-lifetime genetic tests
and then the creation of new order panel
cascades
this might be the the best slide in the
presentation honestly
what we created for consideration for
clack were three new epic order panels
and the goal of these order panels was
to guide providers in the direction
of the optimal guideline compliant test
selections
these panels were initially vetted by
hematology specialists
as well as our cardiology specialists
and they had reached out to me
specifically
requesting an amyloid evaluation panel
to be used in their heart failure clinic
so our clinical laboratory advisory
committee approved these proposed panels
with an initial launch that occurred
in the summer of 2020. so i want to
point out some key features
of these panels for the screening panel
which is depicted at the top of the
slide
we opted to continue with serum protein
electrophoresis with reflex
to immunofixation as opposed to default
ordering
and ife study for all the screens
we clearly stated on the myeloma screen
panel the sensitivity of that
combination of tests
for all plasma cell disorders which
is over 94 percent and really 100
if you're just considering multiple
myeloma we wanted to provide that
information really to reassure providers
that this was an
optimal combination of tests
if you look down at the amyloid
evaluation panel
we included urine studies and that was
on purpose to maximize sensitivity
of detection and then if you look down
at the
monitoring panel for myeloma we made
urine studies an
unchecked option uh in the follow-up or
monitoring setting
now if you go back all the way to the
one of the first slides i showed you and
you the concept of the nudge
um i want to go back to that because we
built these panels without restricting
choice
uh in other words all the tests can
still be ordered
individually by the clinician and the
pre-checked options can be modified
uh at any time the text selections are
clear to the provider and it's really
easy to opt out and that's really
key in the nudge you want to make it
transparent and easy to opt out
so that you preserve provider choice
so it would have been nice if the
expected modifications had been
immediately successful however
we encountered implementation challenges
those included
things like difficulty finding all the
epic locations where
non-optimal test orders were located in
addition to the fact epic has a
functionality now
where physicians can create their own
preference lists within epic so you when
you're trying to do search and replace
functions
with test orders it can be very
challenging
the other thing we recognize was that
despite calling out the new panel
options
we wanted to market them and let
physicians know that they were available
and we did that through our regular
physician communication channels
there was still despite the
communication a high likelihood
that the updates we were sending were
were going to be missed by physicians in
their inboxes
so ultimately we discovered that despite
our effort
all the appropriate preference lists we
originally assumed had been updated in
august of 2020 in fact
had not been updated the updates
had only occurred on inpatient ordering
contacts with an epic
not the ambulatory list which were
actually more crucial for the success of
our project
and the way we discovered this was by
closely monitoring for
some expected impacts so first we looked
for
impacts to test volumes we were looking
for things like
fewer serum protein electrophoresis only
orders
or increased free light chain orders
second we partnered with our epic order
specialist
to create an order panel utilization
report
using the clarity database that's built
within epic monitoring that report
became very helpful for us because it
confirmed to us that the new panels were
only being used in the inpatient setting
which was very odd
to me so it prompted us to take quick
action
to address the problem and ask the
orders team whether or not the
outpatient
ordering contacts have been updated with
the appropriate with the appropriate
panels
so i wanted to show you an example of a
custom report that we generated using
epic slicer dicer if you're unfamiliar
with epic
slicer dicer is a self-service query
tool that's built within epic
and it allows users like me to have
quick view into patient populations
the data are pulled from the back end of
the epic data warehouse
so what this report demonstrates and i
apologize
that the axi axes are so small and you
can't really see but what it's
demonstrating
is the monthly number of encounters in
which there is a protein electrophoresis
order
concurrent with a serum free light chain
order
and the timeline goes from august of
2020 that's the first data point
all the way to april of 2021 the last
data point
and so what we have observed is a very
significant uptick in the monthly number
of orders that are considered guideline
compliant
and that change really flipped for us
between february
and march of this year
we also monitor a monthly order panel
utilization report again
as i mentioned generated automatically
via the epic clarity database
this monthly report actually is emailed
it comes to my inbox every month
and we can clearly see if you're looking
at the left-sided graph
the uptick in utilization of the myeloma
screening order panel
and and this is uh the time frame that's
depicted here is from january of 21
all the way to april 21.
on the other hand if you look at the
right side that's the amyloidosis
evaluation panel utilization
it remained rather stable throughout
that same time period
and that's because our impact had
happened earlier
we had quickly been able to get uptake
of utilization with the small group of
cardiologists because
they were engaged they had asked for the
panel and they began using it
immediately so we had impacted change
back at the end of 2020 so
for 2021 we just demonstrate stability
of utilization by that group
if you look at overall utilization of
all our new order panels
and i don't have this depicted on the
slide but it went from 24 uses in
october of 2020
to 81 total uses during the month of
april of 2021 and that represents an
over 200 percent increase in utilization
of our new panels
and this slide further demonstrates our
success
uh particularly the success in the
primary care setting
in 2018 2019 that was the initial time
period
for the the data that we
evaluated 80 percent i mentioned this
earlier 80
of our evaluations lacked the serum free
light chain studies
we've been able through our efforts to
reduce that percentage down to 32
percent
lacking serum free light chains and
early this year
another thing we've looked at is serum
protein electrophoresis
only orders those orders went from 11
percent of all diagnostic workups in
2020
down to only 3 percent in early 2021.
so in conclusion our audit findings
highlighted a gap
in test order optimization
here in our system we leverage various
tools in epic
however where you are you may have
another electronic medical record or
laboratory information system and i'm
sure they have similar tools
that make the investigative work much
easier
so with the availability of tools like
the ones i've shown
identifying opportunities quite honestly
is the easy part
guiding change however is a much more
challenging position to be in
so really active engagement with
clinician leaders
via a laboratory stewardship committee
like the one we have here is a very very
important strategy
as the laboratory medical director it's
also
very important to cultivate
relationships with other health system
leaders
leaders like the chief information
officer your chief medical information
officer your chief
quality officer and others these
relationships
strengthen the laboratory position and
particularly when you're trying to make
changes with your health system you have
to have the buy-in
if you're changing clinical practice or
making changes with the
emr you've got to have buy-in from your
other clinical and administrative
leaders within your system
and i'll leave you with one last
take-home message
and that is as laboratorians we are in a
position
of privilege that is we have line of
sight
to the ordering behavior of all our
clinicians in our system
and as a response to that we have the
responsibility
to leverage our unique position to drive
conversations about the patterns we
observe
and to nudge health care providers again
nudge health care providers
to optimal test choices
so with that i really want to move into
the q a time and happy to answer any
questions you might have
thank you dr hart for that informative
presentation
we are now going to start the live q a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so dr hart let's get started in your
study
you cited primary care as your target
improvement area
how did other clinical specialty areas
compare from a compliance perspective
so that's a very good question and one
we were also
interested in because we we do know that
these type studies are used by diverse
specialties
the nephrologists in our system
neurologists in our system
also frequently are orders of
these panels of tests so um
in the abstract that we published
we specifically called out our
nephrology and neurology specialists
they were slightly more compliant with
the
the test the optimal test guidelines i
think
if i recall the nephrologists were 26
compliant with guidelines and the
neurologists
were 17 compliant so still
quite a gap it was a little bit more
difficult for us to
understand compliance for
the hematologists oncologists because we
weren't entirely sure when we evaluated
the data set we had to make the
assumptions as i mentioned in my talk
that they were mon they were ordering
primarily for the purpose of
confirmation
or for monitoring and so for
confirmation for example
if an outpatient primary care evaluation
included you know a limited test or a
serum protein electrophoresis only
and the the uh oncologist followed up
with a free light chain study it
appeared in the data set to look like it
was just a free light chain only order
so it was very a little bit more
difficult for us to make definitive
conclusions
about the patterns of test ordering on
the oncologist
great thank you so much dr hart moving
on to our next question
how long would you say it took your
health system to implement this project
so if i were to go back through um
my email inbox and try to find the very
first time
that i initiated a a request to our it
here it probably if i added up all the
months
it would be probably 12 to 15 months and
that seems like
a lot but it quite honestly could have
been longer and i i know from prior
experiences that these projects can tend
to drag out
long long long periods of time and and
it becomes very frustrating for the
laboratory because you
expect to see progress and you don't see
it and you don't know why you see it
so um i would say that
for our system uh we have a
very collaborative relationship between
our epic
i.t folks and our laboratorians and so
through regular meetings through emails
phone calls
we're able to move things through very
quickly now i
i did mention in the talk that we did
vet this
uh project through uh leadership here in
our health system and that that can
add a little bit of a delay but our our
laboratory advisory committee meets
uh every other month and med exec meets
every month so honestly
those are very reasonable timelines i
think for for implementing projects
um the hard part
uh the thing that that took a lot
quite a bit of time was um
getting the utilization reports built
and so we we had to go back and forth
with our epic order specialist to create
that custom report so that i could
really have a line of sight to who was
using
our newly created panels and so
that that honestly can be a quite a bit
of time can elapse for systems
where um you know you're wondering what
the response is and
you're looking for an unexpected
response and you don't see it
and so getting the custom report built
so that we
knew you know so that we could really
evaluate clearly
uh what the impact uh was
um and getting that that report right
uh was probably the the the
the biggest challenge for us
understandably and you know going back
to a time just a follow-up question you
know
what were the most time-consuming
elements of it
yeah i think getting that that custom
utilization report
that was probably the the longest step
and really you know monitoring for
efficacy you just can't neglect that
part and
and we would go back and forth and i
think i mentioned in the talk that we
we first um it took months a couple
months for us to realize that the only
providers who were using the new panels
were inpatient providers
and really the inpatient setting is not
where
the majority of these workups are
happening and we were not seeing
outpatient providers use them and we
wondered why is that
and so i had to go back and forth with
our epic orders team and we had to
figure out where the order panels
had been placed what preference lists
they were on which
preference lists were they not on and so
that's probably the most time consuming
part was figuring out are these order
panels
in the proper location within the emr so
they get seen
by the providers you want to see them
thank you so much dr hart and we want to
thank our audience for all these amazing
questions that are coming in
so dr hart our next one what do you
think are the most effective ways for
laboratories to influence
clinician behavior
yeah that's a very good question um
going back to the concept of the nudge i
think
that's a very important concept because
um
when we don't see the results that we
want to see
it might be um our knee-jerk reaction
might
not be to nudge but to complain or you
know
not go about it in the optimal way i
think nudging clinicians
in the right direction can involve
sometimes some subtle things
um like again building the choices
within the electronic medical record
in such a way that
um it's it's not
not difficult for a clinician to do the
right thing
and so that i think that that order
panel design
uh naming of of tests
those are maybe indirect ways but
they're very important ways that
that the laboratory can influence uh
clinicians
clearly forming relationships
is crucial and so when i first came to
to my current role within the first
six months that i was here i made a
point to visit every single
department head in our system and to go
to their office and to
have time and sit down with them and ask
them what
were their you know what were their
concerns from a laboratory perspective
and forming those relationships from the
very start
of my tenure here was very very
important i think has
has positioned the laboratory in a very
positive
light in our health system
so dr hart our next question is a
two-part question for you
first portion is can you comment on your
involvement with epic
in getting the panels up and running and
the second portion
do you have any additional words of
wisdom
sure so to get those panels
up and running um
i initially created
again what the panels looked like what
tests
uh were included in the panels gave them
a name
um then again they were vetted by the
clinical laboratory advisory committee
and on that committee
we have representation from both the
inpatient
uh epic team and the ambulatory epic
team
so once they were vetted
by the advisory committee
and then approved by medical executive
committee
i it really was back and forth
between me and the epic team making sure
that the the
or new order panels were on the
appropriate preference lists
and then working directly with the epic
team in order to create the custom
reports that we needed in order to
monitor for
uptake and efficacy
as far as additional words of wisdom
i would say one of the things we have
tried
to do here and um so i meet monthly with
our chief information officer
and early on
i tried to convince him that
um the
laboratory was a gold mine of data and
so
um i see the mission of i.t
and the mission of the laboratory to be
very similar
and that you know the laboratory has
tons of data
the electronic medical record has tons
of data and we're trying to
to uh evaluate the data
and and then derive insights from the
data
and then um
present the data to make decisions and
so
what we've done here is really try to
integrate
uh both our lis team uh the epic orders
team
and there's a bunch of different it
teams our bi team
uh we've really tried to integrate with
the lab in fact recently
this was within the last two years we
hired a clinical lab data analyst
who um you know we hired to be
to sit within the laboratory and yet
that individual
has a direct line of connection to the
epic
bi team and so that further cemented the
relationship between
the i.t side and the laboratory side
quite honestly the laboratory is the
only department within our health system
who's chosen a model like that with
regard to data analytics
so dr hart our next question for you is
a two-part question as well
you mentioned difficulty in creating
awareness of the new order options
what avenues did you use to communicate
the new order options
and the second part was it email only or
were there other communication tools
your hospital uses to
communicate such changes
yeah so this is a great question and
it's a challenge for any health system
how do you get
important information to very busy
clinical providers and so we actually
opted
uh in this case to stick with the
regular communication channel that we
have in our system to communicate to
providers and that is through a weekly
email flash that goes out so
all of the content related to these new
order panels we sent out via
this regular email update
now recognizing that
communication is a challenge that's
where the
design of the order panel build and how
it's placed in the emr
becomes very important because with a
really well designed nudge
you may not even require
some official marketing campaign or
communication
uh because you've created you positioned
the new order panel in such a way that
it becomes hard not
to use it and so in a day and age where
providers are so uber busy and
communication is a challenge
really that order panel design and how
you place it in the emr becomes even
more important and so the second half of
that question was
uh about whether we used email
i think i answered that yes so so yeah
it was primarily email
great thank you so much dr hart and
before we let you go for the day we've
got one final question for you
do you have any advice for other health
systems out there who are looking to
implement
a project like this
yeah um be patient and
and and don't give up
uh honestly the hard part is not
the getting the panel out there it's
the hard work of monitoring for efficacy
so you
you know you've got to do that part
because you're you you can't really
improve
without making sure that what you have
done has had the
intended impact and so that can take
months
and and in our case uh
it did take additional months of
figuring out
what the implementation roadblocks were
but by doing that and
really looking for expected impacts then
ultimately you can get to where you you
hope to be
thank you again dr hart for your time
today and for your important research
we'd also like to thank labyrinth and
our sponsor binding site
for underwriting today's educational
webcast before we go i'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions that we did not have time for
today
and those submitted during the odd
demand period will be addressed by our
speaker via the contact information that
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
laborats will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time thank you for joining
bye everyone